hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast i'm your host sean
carroll
and i'm recording this podcast around
noontime pacific
on saturday january 9th 2021
now longtime listeners will know that
i'm usually not that specific
about when things are being recorded in
part because i want to be flexible about
when they're released and so forth
and in part because we aim here not for
currency
of the moment responding to events that
are going on in real time
but rather the big questions the eternal
truths the issues that are going to
matter
for long-term uh consequences today's a
little bit different this is a special
episode that i'm doing
on the fly um that means that a couple
of podcasts that were scheduled got
bumped a little bit
sorry folks but that's okay you'll
appear eventually but those of you who
know well actually let me
state it this way you know we'd like to
be very um
considerate of those archival historians
500 years in the future who are bravely
going through
all the mindscape episodes one by one to
see what people 500 years previously
thought so for those folks i should
explain what's going on here
okay so right now as of this moment
donald trump
is the president of the united states
but he lost an election
back in november and ordinarily this
would not be a big deal the votes were
counted it was clear that he lost
but he didn't accept he didn't concede
he did not
believe that he lost the election and he
and his allies
spread the idea that the election had
been stolen
so on a couple days ago january 6th
wednesday
this was the day when the electoral
college which is the bizarre system
united states uses to
elect a president uh their votes had
already been cast but they were going to
be counted
and approved in congress in the united
states senate
and so this was the last chance before
the election was completely certified
and trump
uh had a big rally on in the united
states capital
uh and sorry in washington dc the
capital city of the united states
and he mentioned uh that he's not going
to let it happen
he told his supporters after this we're
going to walk down and i'll be there
with you we're going to walk down to the
capitol
and he said we've come to demand that
congress do the right thing and only
count the electors who've been lawfully
slated in other words
he's telling his supporters that he does
not want
this usually formality
pro forma acceptance of the electoral
college results to go forward in
congress and they're going to walk down
to the capitol
of course he didn't do that he said i'm
going to walk down with you and he went
back to his office and
and hid there but the uh people who were
in
the protest many of them quite a large
mob of people descended upon the u.s
capitol
overran the police and uh took it over
did a lot of damage a lot of vandalism
um there were
it's really not you know i'm saying this
in some way dracula tone it was not at
all funny
it was quite serious there were some of
the people there
uh were clearly trained and looking uh
for bad things to do there were people
with guns there were people with
explosive devices there were people with
zip ties and other things you could use
to get hostages
there was talk of hanging people a lot
of the protesters were just sort of
there for the lark right you know
they're basically tourists and you know
having a good time instagramming the
whole thing but a couple of
of them were a little bit more serious a
little bit more nefarious and i think
there were
in some sense quite fortunate that no
one died i mean
sorry people did die so we're not in any
sense fortunate
a couple people died i think five is the
fatality count as of right now
um but what i mean is we're fortunate
that no members of congress
died in the whole thing it could easily
have happened
anyway congress uh went back to work the
next
the as soon as the people were removed
from the capital
and they actually did certify the
results of the election
and it nevertheless has shaken us up and
you know things are still changing this
is a
uh that's why i'm exactly time stamping
where we are
because events are happening very very
rapidly and
i can't even tell you what the events
are going to happen between now and when
i release this podcast on monday january
11th
but all that is to say this is a
time for reflecting on what democracy is
and how it is supposed to work and
that's what i want to talk about
i've already had a few podcasts in the
last couple months on democracy
in different senses but i want to home
in on this idea
of failure modes for democracy and what
we can do
about it i'm not pretending to be an
expert on history or democratic theory
or anything
like that but my attitude is that this
is our responsibility
we should all be talking about these
things this is part of what it means to
be
a citizen in a democracy that we
participate
it is not a passive thing so this is not
something to leave to the experts it's
absolutely something where we should
listen to experts i'm always a big
believer in that
but we should listen to the experts and
then keep talking about it it's an
ongoing conversation
an ongoing discourse not just learning
things then going home
democracy is a really weird thing you
know we take it for granted
in a country like the united states
we're very proud of our democratic
traditions
uh it seems to most people to be the
obviously
best form of government footnote there
of course people argue about
republic versus democracy that's a silly
argument you can be a democratic
republican that's what we are
okay my point here is that it really
is asking a lot of the citizens
in a democracy to take up this
responsibility to
govern their own country and some of
them do a good job at it some of them
don't and we can
think about that also the theory of
democracy
is intellectually fascinating right the
idea that rather than
a boss up on top having the
responsibility in telling people what to
do
rather than that there is some emergent
collective behavior
that bubbles up from the people to the
governing apparatus is kind of
fascinating
there are analogs to this in nature in
various ways
uh but there's no one right way to do it
so it's worth thinking through
the specific mechanisms that we use to
make democracy um
go from theory to action and finally
there is um the fact that there these
protests a couple days ago were very
violent
right i think a lot of people are
focusing on that you know it's a shock
to the system
when you see that kind of violence in
what is supposed to be
the peaceable deliberation of political
conflicts and that's a natural focus of
attention
but i'm actually not that interested in
the violence i'm not going to talk about
you know
how many cops or national guards people
we should have
guarding the capital or you know who
instigated what or whatever
i do want to talk about the factors that
led us to the place where you could
imagine
having this kind of violent reaction um
you know the capital has not been
breached in previous
times you know the idea that a
relatively disorganized
mob of rabble could just break into the
capitol
and start you know busting into congress
people's offices and taking their
laptops
is not something i would have actually
um imagined just a few weeks ago i mean
i was completely
ready for a demonstration even a violent
demonstration even a demonstration that
uh went to the capitol building and
tried to break in
i never imagined that they would succeed
and so that's a little weird thing but
again the the tactical issues of the
demonstration
as interesting and fascinating as they
are
aren't my point here why in the world
would that ever be
able to happen and what can we do about
it what does it tell us
about how democracy is going is it
something that we can prevent
going forward what does it mean for the
people who in some sense
won right you know as as dramatic as
that riot slash demonstration was
they lost right you know the the
mainstream consensus opinion
is that it was bad uh they were wrong in
fact there's
pretty significant backlashes against
many people who
not only supported that kind of thing
but weren't even sufficiently against it
so in some sense we can pat ourselves in
the back and say you know okay we're
doing okay
well what does it mean to be doing okay
you know what is the correct response to
this kind of thing how do we deal with
those people
who are on the other side this is the
crucial question
of what it means to live and function in
a democracy
what is our attitude toward the people
we disagree with
and i think that this is an example
where everyone no matter what side
you're on no matter how involved you are
there's some difficult choices to be
made in these
um questions and so that's what i want
to talk about so in fact i'll give you a
little preview in case
you might just be bored and don't listen
to the whole thing i've narrowed it down
i have lots of things to say you know
long time listeners will also know
i can talk at great length about many
things for better for worse
so i've narrowed it down to five
questions that i want to talk about so
first is
how should we think about these dramatic
let's say let's not prejudice uh
the the idea i was gonna say outrageous
but these dramatic
claims in the political arena such as
the election was stolen right that is a
dramatic claim it has enormous
consequences
you might be initially skeptical what is
the epistemic stance we should take
towards such a thing do we have some
responsibility
to take it seriously or can we dismiss
it more or less immediately
second question is what is the role of
violence
and violent action in political change
can we just say
something like all violence is wrong or
are there times when the violent action
is actually justified and if that's true
if sometimes it's justified then we have
to be a little more nuanced about
condemning it right we can't say well
it's violence therefore i condemn it
we have to say it's the wrong kind of
violence which is a much more difficult
thing
to work through but maybe that's what we
have to do um the third question is
do we take the lesson here that our
democracy is fragile
right you know people have certainly
been pointing this out for quite a while
now that just because our democracy has
lasted for a couple centuries doesn't
mean it lasts forever
no other democracy has ever lasted
forever uh
how fragile is it is it is it really
plausible that even if we survive the
next couple weeks
uh the next few years might be a
different story uh and if so how could
we shore it up you know you can't
predict the future exactly
so what are the steps we can take to
make democracy in the united states and
elsewhere a little bit more robust
um then the next question is as i
alluded to earlier what is the sort of
personal stance we should take toward
let's say our opponents right not just
people we disagree with but people we
disagree with
a lot you know really deep down um
are they simply our enemies or does
living in a democracy
demand that we find some accommodation
to live with them even if not happily
then at least
peaceably and finally the last question
we'll talk about is
how can we make things better not just
by changing democratic institutions and
shoring them up
but by convincing other people that
democracy is important and they should
not do things like storm the capitol
building how do we change
people's minds and this is an easy
question to be fatalist about
because we all know some people whose
minds will never change right who are
just not worth talking to but i'm a firm
believer there are other people whose
minds can change i think that's
kind of obvious since people's minds
change as an empirical fact people's
minds do change
how do we make that happen especially in
this world where we're so
splintered and social media are so
important now
and the whole communication process
and news gathering and information
network thing
is way different than it used to be just
a few years ago we had to
totally rethink this question of
um persuasion and making our case for
our positions
in a democratic free speech kind of
society
okay so those are what things i want to
talk about i've already been talking for
a while so let's go
[Music]
you may have noticed something about
politicians namely that
they do not always tell the truth
politicians sometimes lie or at least
let's say
shade a completely accurate
representation of the facts
that's not surprising and you know maybe
even in
certain cases it's not even bad you know
you can
get things done while not being
completely candid about what you're
doing and if what you
get done is for the better you could
make some kind of instrumental argument
that it's for the best
but there's untruth and then there's
untruth right uh
there's different sizes of lies that
politicians can put forward to the
people and there's
different amounts of egregiousness that
those lies
can be labeled with so the first
question that i want to talk about is
you know how should we deal with claims
made by
politicians or elites right people in
the media people with large
platforms uh that seem to be
completely dramatically wrong on the
face of them you know what is the thing
that we should do about them and what i
mean is
i mean again i'm trying to uh not
prejudice the answer
right away uh i'm imagining that some
claim is made
that in ordinary circumstances would
seem very unlikely to us
okay we don't need to go into details
about exactly what criteria
what situations what conditions that
would be but there's basically two kinds
of attitudes that you might
reasonably think taking one is if the
claim is just so outrageous sounding
uh we just dismiss it we just don't
really give it any credence right we say
oh come on
we're not gonna take any uh of our
valuable time and put it into worrying
about that
but there's another perfectly reasonable
sounding attitude that says look
if if someone in power some elite
someone with a big
platform someone with a track record of
one form or another
makes this kind of outrageous claim uh
it is our duty
to at least give it a hearing right to
at least take it seriously enough to
listen to the evidence to
let the data come in and then make an
informed
decision based on whatever data that is
in the particular
example we're thinking of here the claim
is that the 2020 presidential election
was
stolen by joe biden and kamala harris
and the democratic party and that the
fact that they got more votes
was a fake was cheating something like
that okay
and therefore the election result was
illegitimate that's the claim
we're thinking about now let me tell you
right away what my attitude toward that
claim is
it is complete nonsense it is
way false it is egregious [ __ ] if
you want to go back to
the podcast i did with carl bergstrom a
little while ago
using [ __ ] in a technical sense
right here okay the election was
not stolen um and there's a lot of
reasons you can put forward to that but
what i'm
really interested in is you know what
should our
toolkit be epistemically for dealing
with something like that
even if it sounds like egregious
[ __ ] should we nevertheless
spend some time taking it seriously
because if it is true it would be very
very big
i think that's the um calculus what
we're what we're weighing here right
something might seem very unlikely but
if it's true it's dramatically
dramatically important so
at what point does the dramatical
dramatic importance of a claim
outweigh the fact that it seems very
unlikely to us
and in fact in this particular case you
know the the idea that the election was
stolen was made by a whole bunch of
partisan actors
but it was also i think importantly
taken up as something worth considering
even if not necessarily true
by various contrarian centrist pundits
right a small set of them you know not a
majority of them but
there's a certain way of being kind of
naughty
and showing that one is
anti-establishment and not beholden to
the conventional wisdom
that one gets by saying well sure you
know this might be wrong i'm not saying
it's right that the election was stolen
but it's at least worth letting the
process
play out listening to what they have to
say and so forth
okay so the answer i want to put forward
is no
it was never worth taking that kind of
claim
seriously and you can justify this in a
number of different ways right we like
to talk here about being bayesian
in fact it's almost kind of a cliche in
certain corners of the internet
talking about being good bayesians and
and what that's what is meant by that
is for a set of propositions like the
election was stolen the election was not
stolen okay two propositions mutually
exclusive so
you assign prior probabilities or prior
credences
to these propositions being true so you
might say well
elections are not usually stolen so the
credence i would put on that claim my
prior is very very
uh small and the greens i would put on
it not being stolen is very large
but then a good bayesian says you let
the information come in
you collect data and you have what is
called a likelihood function
the likelihood is a way of saying if
this proposition were true
it's either certain it's how likely is
it
that that particular data would be
collected right
and i think that in a lot of these
discussions about being a good bayesian
reasoner
a lot of attention is paid to one's
priors
what it means to have a prior and it
makes perfect sense from a sort of
philosophy of probability point of view
that that's a fascinating topic worthy
of a lot of discussion because it makes
probabilities sound kind of subjective
and i think the answer is yes
they are subjective because after all
the election was or it was not stolen
right i mean this is not flipping a coin
this is something that already happened
and you're assigning a credence a degree
of belief to one
attitude or another that's a subjective
thing to do
okay so a lot of attention is given to
that and then also a lot of attention is
given to the idea that
when information comes in you should
update your priors via this likelihood
to function
but usually attention is most often
focused on the idea that
information comes in that changes your
priors
in a significant way right the fact the
idea that
the data that comes in is exactly could
be
it might be true that the data that
comes in is exactly what you would have
expected
i think is kind of underemphasized this
is a thing that can happen
right so in a case like this where a
bunch of people are saying
oh there was election fraud
irregularities you know
the counting was off by this way or that
way it all seems suspicious
you should ask yourself did i expect
that to happen
the point is that if you expected
exactly those claims to be made
even if the underlying proposition that
the election was stolen
is completely false then seeing those
claims being made
provides zero evidence for you to change
your credences
whatsoever okay so to make that abstract
statement a little more down to earth
in the case of the elections being
stolen
how likely was it that if donald trump
did not
win the election that he and his allies
would claim the election was stolen
independent of whether it was
okay what was what was the probability
that he was going to say
that there were irregularities and it
was stolen well a hundred percent
roughly speaking 99.999 if you want to
be a little bit
more metaphysically careful but they
announced ahead of time
that they were going to make those
claims right he had been
saying for months uh that the very idea
of voting by mail
is irregular and was going to lead to
fraud and
they worked very hard to make the
process
difficult both to cast votes and then to
count them
different states had different ways of
counting certain states were
prohibited from counting mail-in ballots
ahead of time the democrats were much
more likely to vote by mail
than the republicans were they slowed
down the postal service trying to make
it
take longer for mail-in votes to get
there there's a whole bunch of things
going on
in prior elections in the primaries
trump had accused his opponents
of rigging the election and stealing
votes without any evidence
so your likelihood function that you
would see these claims
rise up even if the underlying
proposition was not true
is basically a hundred percent and
therefore as a good bayesian
the fact that people were raising
questions about the integrity of the
election
means nothing it's just what you
expect to happen if you really want
to spend any effort at all taking a
claim like this
seriously you have to go beyond that
simple thing you know oh
someone claimed that something's going
on therefore it's my job to
evaluate it and wait for more evidence
to come in you should ask further
questions what
else should i expect to be true if this
claim was correct for example
if the democrats had somehow been able
to
get a lot of false ballots right
elections you would expect to see
certain patterns
like democrats winning a lot of
elections they had been
predicted to lose uh different cities
where or locations more broadly where
the frauds were purported to happen
would be ones where
anomalously large percentages of people
were voting
for biden rather than trump in both
cases in both the idea that you would
predict
democrats winning elections they had
been predicted to lose and
places where fraud was alleged to have
happened would be anomalously pro-biden
it was the opposite and you could
instantly see
that it was the opposite right after
election day
uh the democrats lost elections
for the house of representatives and the
senate that they were favored to win
so they were very bad at uh packing the
ballots if that's really what they were
trying to do
in cities like philadelphia where it was
alleged that a great voter fraud was
taking place
trump did better in 2020 than he did in
2016.
so right away without working very hard
you know this is egregious
[ __ ] okay there is no duty
uh to think to take seriously to spend
your time
worrying about the likely truth of this
outrageous claim
all of which is completely compatible
with every evidence the
the falsity of which is completely
compatible with all the evidence we have
so just to make it dramatic let me spend
a little bit of time here
let me let me give you an aside which is
my favorite example of what i mean
by this kind of attitude because it is
very tricky
you should never i'm very happy to admit
you should never assign
zero credence to essentially any crazy
claim
right that would be bad practice as a
good bayesian because if you assign
zero credence to any claim then
no amount of new evidence would ever
change your mind okay
you're taking the prior probability
multiply the likelihood but if the prior
probability is zero
then it doesn't matter what the
likelihood is you're always going to get
zero at the end
and you should be open to the idea
that evidence could come in that this
outrageous claim is true that the
election was stolen it's certainly
plausible
that such evidence would come in now it
didn't right when actually they did
have their day in court they were
laughed out of court because they had
zero evidence even all the way up to
january 6th
when people in congress were raising a
stink about the election not being fair
they still had no evidence the only
claim they could make was that
people were upset and people had
suspicions right even months later
so there was never any evidence that it
was worth taking seriously
but nevertheless even without that i do
think you should give
some credence and therefore you have to
do the hard work of saying
well i'm giving it some non-zero
credence
but so little that it's not really worth
spending even a minute
worrying about it that's a very crucial
distinction to draw and it's very hard
to do so the crazy example i like to use
is the claim that the moon is made of
green cheese as
i said i've used this before but let me
spend a couple of minutes explaining
what i mean
so someone says to you you know i think
the moon is made of green cheese
and you say well and you you decide to
take them seriously right you're trying
to be a good rational actor
bayesian interlocutor you say well i
don't think that's true
you know we have telescopes and we've
looked at the moon it doesn't look like
it's made of green
cheese we can take its spectrum it
doesn't look like you know the spectrum
of green cheese
and your friend could say well that's
just because the surface of the moon the
you know the top one centimeter is not
green cheese it's like a thin layer of
um
moon dust but below that it's green
cheese and you could say well you know
we've actually gone to the moon we've
taken back
samples we've returned them to earth and
analyzed them
furthermore we know the density of the
moon right we know the total mass of the
moon from its gravitational field
it's not the density you expect cheese
to have
and your friend says well you have to
understand that lunar green
cheese has a different density than
terrestrial green cheese that's obvious
you know who would expect anything other
and for that matter you know once you
pick it up and put it into your sample
bag then it converts from green cheese
into moon dust so of course you don't
have any evidence
that you brought back that it's green
cheese okay so
my there are two lessons that i want to
take from this completely silly
concocted ludicrous example
one is you can always
uh wriggle out of any evidence that
purports to be against any
claim whatsoever right it's not a matter
of whether something is probable or not
but just as a matter of whether
something is
conceivable any crazy claim is
conceivable this is a fact
in the practice of science that science
does improve things with metaphysical
certitude it just gathers evidence and
creeps up
on greater and greater credences in
claims that we think are true
so you don't just say to the claim of
the moon is made of green cheese that's
impossible that's the wrong attitude to
take
okay but also the much more subtle and
interesting
fact is the fact that when you gave your
counter arguments well you know we've
looked at the moon we've brought pieces
back we know what the density is
you're lying to yourself you're not
being honest
because those are not the reasons why we
think the moon is not made of green
cheese right
long before we invented spectra or
brought samples back from the moon or
accurately measured its mass
we already knew that the moon was not
made of green cheese
and the reason why is because it's
embedded in a bigger context
when you set your priors as a good
bayesian for these kinds of claims
you don't you're not under any
obligation to forget everything you know
about reality
in fact you're under the opposite
obligation you need to take into account
what you know about reality so in the
case of the moon
the fact that you are able to bring a
sample back is nice
but long before you were able to do that
you have an idea of what it means to be
cheese
right it comes from cows or sheeps or
goats and you get their milk and you
process it in the right way
okay there was never any sensible idea
that the moon would be made of green
cheese it's just a joke
right so you're allowed to use that
information you're allowed to use that
background information and so the
correct attitude when someone says oh i
think the moon is made of green cheese
is not to take it seriously and sort of
provide
evidence from science and whatever it's
just to say you know whatever dude
i know better than that i'm going to go
on with my life
and this is an example of that the idea
that the election was stolen
without any evidence being put forward
when they told us ahead of time that
they were going to say that
deserves nothing more than a whatever
dude
i don't need to take that seriously
and i think you know i feel strongly
about this because it's more than just a
little political
tiff it has to do with how we think
right this is a much
a lesson of much wider applicability
when you spend time when you spend your
cognitive powers thinking and trying to
be clever and refuting these completely
egregiously wrong claims you degrade
your own
cognitive capacity you damage your own
ability
to separate reasonable ideas from
unreasonable ones
and so it is completely okay in other
words i would argue
when people are making claims about this
election being stolen without any
evidence
in complete contradiction of everything
that we actually saw happen
to just say no it's not worth taking
seriously
and if it were just your friends or you
know people on facebook making these
claims
you could do that the difficulty of
course here is that it's being done by
officials at the highest level of the
government and that is
a problem and we'll get to that later in
the podcast
okay it's never a bad time to do good
deeds givewell is a non-profit that
helps us do that
by searching for charities where our
donations help the most
in 2021 givewell has a special program
where any listener who starts a new
monthly donation by the end of february
will have their first month matched
up to 250 dollars when you make a
monthly donation you're committing to
helping others all year long by giving
to the most cost-effective charities
givewell has found
every month you'll automatically work
towards saving lives preventing deadly
disease
or helping those in extreme poverty the
idea of giving to charity
helps tickle the virtuous part of
ourselves but givewell helps
the rational part of our brains feel
good about it too
whether you're new to givewell or
already a donor any listener who starts
a new monthly donation by the end of
february will have their first month
matched up to 250 dollars
to have the donation matched just go to
givewell.org
mindscape choose to give monthly and
pick podcast and sean carroll's
mindscape at checkout
that's givewell.org mindscape select
podcast and mindscape at checkout
the next question i want to look at is
this idea of
violence okay what is the role of
violent action
in political change we all know or
not you 500 years from now historians
how's it going there
but those of us who are living here in
january 2021 know that there was
violence
on january 6th when the mob stormed the
capital and there was also violence
earlier in the summer of 2020
there were a whole bunch of different
demonstrations uh
roughly centered around the black lives
matter movement just
expressing outrage at the treatment of
black people and other people at the
hands of police and law enforcement more
generally and this is a very complicated
question because
in the summer protests even though there
was violence and there was certainly
property damage it was actually more
property damage than
than violence against other people um
but there was property damage
and it's not clear who exactly was doing
it
you know there it is clear that in some
cases it was being done by people who
were just there
trying to make the protesters look bad
okay or just trying to you know
uh have a good time it had nothing to do
with the underlying political
motivations of the protests going on but
for the purposes
of um this conversation i don't want to
try to adjudicate
exactly which little bit of violence or
property damage was done by who
i just want to sort of figure out what
is the theory of when it is okay
to do violence now in my i'll just give
away
my personal belief about this i don't
think that the
demonstrations this summer or the
demonstration we had on january 6th
should have been violent or caused any
property damage
at all and roughly speaking the reason i
believe this is that
it comes down to deontology versus
consequentialism okay something else
we've talked about before
on the podcast in the context of moral
philosophy
uh in moral philosophy we distinguish
between deontological approaches which
basically say
there are rules of behavior and to be
moral to be ethical to act correctly is
to obey
these rules right and the trick is to
figure out what the rules are
whereas a consequentialist would say
there's it's not that there are rules of
behavior is that there are goals
of behavior we judge a behavior not by
what it is for
itself but but by what its consequences
are
if a behavior makes the world a better
place it's good if it makes the world a
worse place it's bad
and when it comes to moral philosophy
i'm in between i i
i'm not a strict deontologist or
consequentialist i think there are
bits and pieces of both and it's not a
very clean
crisp set of distinctions that one can
easily draw
but for politics and for political
action
i would argue that one should largely be
a consequentialist
because the idea of politics is to shape
the society
right to shape the world around you
especially democratic politics where it
is
a bottom-up kind of system and so the
question we should be asking
ourselves is is the particular action
that we're imagining taking
going to make the world a better place
or not and what that means is
putting aside the question of
will this action i'm contemplating
taking make me feel better
or to again to state it a little bit
less judgmentally from the start
do i think that this action is sort of
intrinsically justified no matter what
its consequences are
is that is that a rational opinion or
attitude to take perspective to have on
these kinds of questions and so i would
argue
not for political kinds of questions you
should always be asking yourself
what will the consequences be and i
think that in
even in the case of the the summer uh
protests which were completely justified
as protests they were protesting against
something that was really bad
um there was no obvious good consequence
or reason
to do property damage or you know to
bust down windows or anything like that
that didn't in my mind
advanced the cause and in fact there are
studies that show
exactly this studies are always hard so
i don't want to say this
you know closes the book on the question
but the studies that i've seen
indicate that you know um non-violent
protests or
peaceful protests violent isn't even the
right word in this case because it's not
really violence when you break a window
but completely peaceful protests uh do a
better job
of affecting public opinion than ones
that are a little bit more
um uh knocking things down
causing a mess right causing a ruckus
okay but again that's an
empirical question that is a difficult
one and maybe further studies will
change my mind about that the point is
that
in those two cases just to be clear i
don't think there's much cause for
violence at all
that is not to draw a distinction
between them
okay i think that it's much much closer
to uh it's a much much closer call in
the case of the black lives matter
protests
for the simple case for the simple
reason that the justification
the the reason why you were protesting
in the first place was a good one rather
than a bad one
okay there is no analogy or direct
parallel to be drawn
between protesting against police
brutality
and protesting against the idea that
your candidate lost an election
right protesting in disbelief of the
results of an election outcome those are
just
not analogous in any way so
overly glib comparisons between them are
also wrong even though i don't think
that
property damage is justified in either
one of those two cases it's not because
they're the same case okay they're
completely different cases and
furthermore i think that
uh in just because i think that in those
two cases there's no reason to knock
down some windows
that doesn't mean in any way that we
should just say
violence is always wrong i can certainly
imagine cases where
violence would be called for right
namely for example when you are
actually protesting against a
dictatorship
rather than protesting uh in order to
keep a dictator
or a would-be dictator in office it's a
big difference right i think that
rebelling against
tyranny is perfectly justified
so it is not at all safe to just say
well i don't like violence and so all
the violent people are bad you need to
think through it a little bit you need
to think through
what exactly is going on i would rather
protest against tyranny or
authoritarianism or dictatorship
non-violently if that could have the
consequence that i saw it
but i am not at all convinced that is
always the case there is a there is a
time for
revolution um in fact it's more than
that let me
let's let me back up a little bit
because i think this is actually
not just a sort of necessary evil but
almost a feature
of democracy not violence per se but the
idea of
unrest the idea of churn of uh
drama of protests and demonstrations
and you know political um
dissatisfaction
okay um exactly because a democracy
is a nuanced complex emergent
bottom-up kind of process rather than a
clean crisp here are the rules from on
high kind of process
it's important that we disagree and that
we try different things that we argue
sometimes quite loudly
for our different things as a much sort
of
more peaceful smaller scale example of
this think about
you know the fact that people on both
sides of the political spectrum are
always
upset with the kids these days the kids
these days
have these crazy ideas one way or the
other right especially kids in college
right oh the college students they're
just
they're not like when we were kids well
we were very reasonable but these days
they have these crazy ideas you know
so i think that it's good that kids in
college have crazy ideas
uh i shouldn't even call them kids i'm
trying to do that in the voice of the
people who were
fetching about it before but college
students
college undergraduate education is a
time of your life
when it is exactly when you should have
the craziest ideas when you should try
on new things right i mean
it's the first time when you sort of
have left home
you're exposed to a completely different
set of people and ideas than what you
grew up with your whole life
um and it's sort of the most form the
most
uh flexible you will be you know as you
get older
you're gonna settle into some set of
beliefs one way or another
so you know those crucial years college
and maybe high school
right maybe even graduate school but
around that time of your life
this is the time for intellectual
exploration
and also kind of emotional exploration
right being outraged about things
college students care about things in a
way that
for those of us who are beyond those
times of our lives can sometimes just
sort of bleed out of us because we get
tired and
also locked into our opinions and many
of the crazy ideas or the
very emotionally held positions that
young people have are going to be wrong
from the point of view of we wiser old
heads
but i think we should still be glad that
they have them
i do not think that we should complain
about the idea that the kids today
don't think in the same way we do and
the analogy i have in mind
is evolutionary biology right we have a
genome and we pass it on to our
descendants
and we mix and match because of sexual
reproduction and they're also just
mutations right so
our genomes are constantly trying out
new ideas in a very real sense
and most mutations are bad right this is
part of the statistical mechanics of
change in complex systems if you have a
system like a living organism
it's pretty well adapted to its
environment most ways it could change
would make it less well adapted but some
ways it could change will make it better
right that's how improvements happen
over evolutionary time
and so you have to take the bad with the
good a little bit as
a evolving genome over time you have to
try out some ideas that end up being bad
and then discarding them and the reason
why you have to try them out is because
you don't know ahead of time
whether they will be bad you have to try
them first
and in my mind this is an analogy for
how we try out ideas
over the course of our lives and
especially when we're young
we try out different things and we don't
yet completely appreciate all the
consequences or ramifications of those
ideas
so we tend to sort of regress to the
mean a little bit as we get older
but it's crucially important that that
energy that that willingness
to try out new things is there and those
of us who are of a certain age and
for whom our college years were quite a
while ago
should be lenient in that sense should
be willing to
cut some slack to younger people who are
trying out dramatic ideas on either side
of the political spectrum okay and the
wider
scale lesson for democracy is that
we need protests we need people out
there marching
on both sides or not even both sides all
sides
people with all sorts of different ideas
should be out there
making their case both in the
form of ideas and also in physical
manifestations of people marching right
this is part of what democracy is it's a
feature not a bug
okay and as far as violence is concerned
i
not in favor of it happening frequently
i think it should be a last resort
i think that it very often it results
just from sort of a cathartic
emotional very short-term
non-consequentialist
thinking going on on the part of the
people doing it
but sometimes it could be necessary
right sometimes you know things
are bad i mean what if this egregiously
wrong claim the election had been stolen
was right what if the election just had
been stolen by a small cabal of bad
actors
um in the sense that you know it truly
overthrew
the legitimate result of a democratic
election
then absolutely dramatic response would
be called for one way or the other i'm
not
exactly sure what the best response
would be but it would be dramatic and
maybe some windows would have to be
broken so the real disaster of
the the real bad aspect of the disaster
that happened on january 6th
was not primarily that people were
violent or the people were unruly or a
mob
it was that all of their actions were
based on a lie that's why the previous
discussion is so important that
the fact that they were doing these
things could in completely other
circumstances have been justified
but in this actual world in which we
live in the real world where they were
just lied to and they bought it
that's the problem because they did
these terrible things for all of the
wrong reasons and i don't think that you
can separate out the reasons why they do
them
from what it is that they did
it's the new year and we're all looking
for ways to improve ourselves just a
little bit
peloton is a home exercise system that
has world-class instructors curated
music and endless fitness variety
peloton has created an unmatched fitness
experience to keep you motivated
workout after workout what i like about
peloton is that it's convenient it's
right there in your home
it's flexible you can do it when you
need to and if you can't do it at the
time
you can just skip it but it's also
inspiring there's curated music with
epic artist collaborations
instructor curated playlists the music
experience is unlike any other whether
you're in the mood for some hip-hop
pop or country the peloton bike has the
right music to keep you entertained
and motivated all year long it's also
flexible there's not just game changing
cardio
you could add a strength class to your
ride or combine cardio
and strength in one workout with bike
boot camp
to get a total body fitness experience
so get started on your peloton journey
today and download the peloton app
through january 31st 2021 for a
two-month
free trial that's two free months when
you download the peloton app on your
phone
tablet or smart tv
moving on to the third thing i want to
talk about uh this leads right into this
question of the fragility
of democracy right you know again we're
kind of sanguine
uh once you reach the point where a
system of government
has been around longer than the
lifespan of the people who are living in
that society it seems eternal right it
seems kind of permanently baked in right
none of us was alive
at the birth of american democracy um so
it just seems like a feature of the
background just impossible to imagine it
being
any different um but it can be and so
you know during the during the actual
events of january 6
i and probably a few of you folks out
there listening
uh could not help but think back to the
podcast interview i did with edward
watts
on the decline and fall of the roman
republic if you remember that or if you
didn't listen to it i absolutely
encourage you to listen to it
um eduards was talking about the last
years of the republic before the roman
empire grew like we think about the
decline of all the roman empire but
before there was an empire for 500 years
there was a roman republic
right and it was very successful it was
successful both in governance and in
sort of
prosperity and things like that um 500
years a lot longer than american
republic has lasted so far right and but
but it did fall
and there's a lot of things that go into
it falling i mean maybe there's just
some inevitability some time scale that
says like after a while
democracies are sort of self-undermining
and i i i would be willing to entertain
that kind of theory although i don't
know if it's actually true
but in particular there are events you
can point to at crucial
points right at moments in history where
the consequences of small actions could
be very large
and watts points out uh these it's it's
not his
original idea but he highlights the role
of the grakie brothers
grocky is uh g-r-a-c-c-h-i i think
uh these two brothers and both of them
were probably if we were to
uh you know not quite legitimately
shoehorn them into modern um
political categories they were more
leftist than rightist okay they were
more populist they wanted
to take wealth away from the aristocracy
and distribute it among the peasantry
and so
forth okay so a more typical left-wing
point of view but the point was not
what they were actually arguing for the
point was their tactics
uh and edwards points to the fact that
they assembled
mobs right that they you know inflamed
the passions of the people
and they sent these people to
demonstrate and to sort of
threaten the the republic the senators
right
the elected representatives of the
people and
it didn't work at first i mean the rocky
brothers were not actually
you know they didn't take over but what
they did is they set a precedent
they set a precedent that political
disagreements
wouldn't always be settled by
voting uh you could settle them just by
displays of power and that spiraled out
of control
it was his argument that that snowballed
to the point where it went back and
forth with different sets of people
trying to
you know have displays of force and
eventually the whole republic was
overthrown
and at the time i forget when it was
like a year and a half ago when we had
this conversation
um this seemed like a really good
metaphor for what might be going on in
the united states
um that you know different sets of
people were violating norms right that's
the metaphorical relationship between
what happened with the gracky brothers
and the roman republic what was going on
with trump and his allies in the u.s
is that in both cases there were norms
of behavior there were ways of behaving
that were considered okay
and other ways that were not considered
okay and it was not written in stone or
even in
legislation but it was taken for granted
that there are certain ways you behave
in certain ways you don't
and both the gracies and the trumps
violated these norms and that would be
bad
now given the events of the last week we
know that it's not just a metaphor it is
actually pretty close to a literal
parallel
between what is happening now in the
united states and what happened back
then
in ancient rome so all of this is to say
we have to always be cognizant of the
fact that democracies aren't forever
not only can they fail they tend to
fail right another thing that has been a
correct point that was pointed out on
twitter and has been going around
is that coup attempts if you want to
classify
something like this as a coup uh okay we
can argue about whether or not that's
true or not but the point is coup
attempts very often fail
and then later succeed right the failure
of a coup at any one moment in time
is not a guarantee that the underlying
energies that powered it will fade away
and disappear it very often happens that
a few years later
they pop up again and succeed so you
know not to be too alarmist but let's be
alarmist about this this is it's it's
just not at all guaranteed that the
government we grew up with is going to
continue on
forever so we should think about what
the weak points are right we should
think about if
i'm taking for granted the idea that
we're in favor of democracy like you
might not be
i am i'm not actually mostly um doing
this podcast to defend
democracy that's that'll be a different
conversation but let's assume that
you're in favor of democracy okay
you should be worried even if you think
that we didn't really come close
to any uh really disastrous thing going
on over the last week here in january
2021
you should still be worried that in
principle something very bad could
happen
i mean one way of putting it is how
different
if you think and again it's january 9
joe biden's supposed to be
inaugurated on january 20th there's all
sorts of room
in the next few weeks or the next few
years for things to go disastrously
wrong
but under the assumption that democracy
has lived to fight another day
okay that were that we're fine and i
think that's overwhelmingly likely to be
true
in the short term um we can think about
other possible worlds right you know if
you go back to the
philosophy discussion i had with ned
hall a while ago
uh we talked a little bit about the
notion of different possible worlds
worlds that are much like ours but
things are just a little bit different
and you can ask how does a small
change from our world to another one
lead to larger changes
i think that ed watts would have said
you know that you can pinpoint these
moments when the grocke brothers
got their mobs together had they not
done that
that small change would have led to
large changes
in the future of the roman republic
likewise we can ask
are there small changes we can imagine
in our current political
setup that would have led to a much more
disastrous result for our current
democracy
and i think the answer is pretty clearly
yes that that you don't need a very
large change in our current system i
know i think that
even if the system was resilient enough
and it survived um even mitch mcconnell
who uh for someone like me is just a a
huge threat to the good workings of
american governance you know even he
gave a pretty good speech um i don't
want to give him too much credit because
he
was a huge factor behind the problem
happening in the first place but he did
you know say look
we're still a democracy we have to obey
the rules so i'm willing i'm able to
both
condemn him for almost anything and then
give him credit for that
um but so part of that was
that this idea that the election had
been stolen
didn't have quite enough support in
among public officials
for it to really be taken seriously uh
it had support
among some okay um i mean let's let's
point out
in particular there were republicans in
congress you know for those of you in
the future congress is roughly speaking
50 50 democrat and republican
and roughly half of the republicans in
congress so 25
of congress overall um bought into the
idea
that we should not certify the election
results of the electoral college because
of doubts about
the election count because of the
possibility of
fraud not that they'd necessarily said
there was fraud but there was enough
doubt
okay and again for the previous
conversation
they're lying they know better right
they have no evidence that there was any
fraud they know perfectly well
it was a perfectly safe fair reasonable
election
but for political reasons about half
of the republican delegation in congress
so both senate and the house combined
voted to not accept the electoral votes
from the state of arizona for example
and i didn't
even follow all of the machinations
because so they failed so it's only one
quarter of congress overall but
half of the republican party was willing
to go along
with this blatantly and anti-democratic
suggestion because being in a democracy
doesn't just mean you have a vote it
means you respect the results of the
vote
and no matter how safe and secure and
fair an election was
you can always you know throw sand in
people's faces
you can always raise doubts as
ridiculous as the doubts were i mean the
kinds of doubts that were raised
for this election were completely
preposterous there was a bunch of you
know weekend warriors at their keyboards
who knew nothing about the process of
counting votes who were watching the
votes come in
and they were struck with what they
thought were
weird sort of anomalies people who were
experts knew perfectly well that those
were not anomalies at all
again and again many many lawsuits went
forward in court
to challenge the results of these
elections and they were thrown out as
completely ridiculous they didn't just
lose
the these lawsuits were ridiculed by
judges nationwide okay
for a complete lack of evidence there's
really nothing wrong with this election
so
nevertheless half the republican caucus
uh
voted to not take the election as
finished and
done and to be super duper clear about
this or to to
mention the other fact that you need to
take into consideration
the vote i'm talking about uh to reject
the votes of
arizona's elect electors happened after
the mob had taken over the capitol
building and delayed that vote
okay so in other words a mob of rioters
terrorists honestly who were motivated
by a blatant big lie
stormed the capitol building put the
lives of senators and
congress people at risk and it was a
very very real
risk and some people did die right um
it was it was there were fatal incidents
during that mess
offices were ruined etc you know offices
were trashed and
certain famous democratic politicians if
i were them i would have been very very
very worried about my
life uh even mike pence who was the vice
president
right you know supposed to be on trump's
side trump was
denigrating him on twitter as as you
know sort of betraying him
by you know doing his job as the
president of the senate and then letting
the vote go forward and so
he was a target of the rioters so the
point is
after this crazed violent
dangerous demonstration all of which
was motivated by a big lie a deranged
conspiracy theory about the outcome of
the election
still half of the republicans in
congress
voted in favor of that crazed conspiracy
theory
okay so to me that says that it didn't
need
that much of a difference from person to
person to make that outcome be much
worse than it was
now this is you have to be very subtle
here you have to be very careful i
should say because
um there are calculations going on i
mean i think that i just as i
do not think it is a surprise to say
that politicians sometimes lie
politicians also sometimes take votes
which are not necessarily reflective of
what they believe
is true okay they do it for political
reasons
and the fact that there were a
substantial number of people in congress
republicans in congress voting for this
give them gave them some
cover it was not just one or two weirdos
right but the fact that it was
only 25 of congress overall also gave
them cover because there weren't any
consequences for their actions in terms
of
you know congress doing anything about
it so you could try to make the case
that even if a few more
if more people in congress really
believe the election had been stolen
some other members of congress who voted
in that direction would have changed
their vote okay
but you know the very leaders of the
congressional delegations
in the house and the senate uh were not
behind
this whole attempt uh they thought that
we should you know just get on with it
count the votes biden won let's just
accept that and move on
you can imagine that a tiny number of
changes in the leadership
of the republicans in the senate
would have made things very different
certainly a tiny number of changes in
election outcomes
could have put republicans in control of
the house of representatives as well as
the senate
you can imagine that there would be a
few state
legislatures who were
dramatically partisan and therefore
undermine the electoral votes of their
state
you could imagine that there were a few
more judges who were dramatically
partisan and therefore did not laugh
the lawsuits out of court etc
i don't think this is completely
implausible it's it's it's not that you
would need to change
uh the actions of millions of people to
make this happen you have to change the
actions of a few people
to get into a situation where uh the
actual
functioning of democracy would be
dramatically under
undermined something like this more or
less happened in pennsylvania
where there was an election for a state
rep
state senator and it was won by a
democrat
james brewster and the republicans
sued to under to overturn that election
because
there were detailed questions about in
pennsylvania made it especially
difficult
to figure out how to do a mail-in ballot
right there all these very persnickety
rules
and so there's a challenge like you know
how should the date
be put on the envelope if you were
giving a mail-in ballot okay so
republicans sued
perfectly within their rights uh the
pennsylvania court system
looked at the lawsuits and said no we
throw them out
they're not meritorious we should accept
these
ballots and therefore this guy james
brewster
is the rightfully elected senator and
that is the process by which you go
through
and the republicans simply refused to
accept it they said well we'll file
a suit in federal courts which do not
have jurisdiction over this issue but
they said we're going to do it anyway
and when it came time to swear in
uh brewster as a democratic state
senator they didn't do it they refused
to do it they kicked out the lieutenant
governor
from the senate chamber um that kind of
thing can happen
right and that's something that is part
of the system
i think that you know it's almost
trivially true
that if more than 50 of a citizenry
don't believe in democracy in some you
know consistent way like they're all in
agreement with each other and in
disagreement with the idea of democracy
then you can't have a democracy right
you need at least 50 of the citizenry to
believe in it
but i don't think that's you know and
that's a very worrisome thing but that's
always going to be a worry that's just
something we have to take
uh seriously and we i'll talk later
about you know
how we should deal with that possibility
but there's another possibility which is
that even if
almost all the citizens are in favor of
democracy
uh a small but crucial number of elected
officials are not
and they have enormously more power
right
one elected official is not enough right
donald trump by himself or mitch
mcconnell by himself or ted cruz by
himself
could not over overturn the results of
a fair democratic process but a handful
of them
a few dozen let's say you know could do
it right
and i talked about this a couple times
on the podcast i think probably most
recently with ezra klein
when we talked about political
polarization um
there's a game theory question here you
know if you are an elected official
what is your utility what are your goals
what is it that you want to have happen
right and i think that um a couple
things have become clear over the years
that maybe weren't clear
in previous years one is the system is
um it's polarized but it's polarized in
part because it's a winner take all
system right when we vote for
a senator or for a representative or for
president one party wins another party
loses and this is why the united states
is always going to be a two-party system
as long as we have the kind of system of
government we do
if you're the third place party you will
never win any elections right you don't
win a third of the elections or
ten percent of the elections are 20 you
win zero percent
of the elections because it's just too
hard to get uh
over 50 of the vote if you're the third
biggest political party
and therefore if you and if you also
have a situation where
the parties are nationalized right so
this didn't used to be the case but
right now
there's more or less political
homogeneity among the national parties
right
democrats in california and democrats in
idaho
believe more or less in the same things
not exactly
at the margins they're different but
more or less they believe the same
things
and therefore most californians like the
democratic point of view most idahoans
don't like the democratic point of view
and so
if you want to win statewide office in
idaho
you don't run as a democrat it's just
pointless you're never going to win
that can change of course over time but
currently that's the that is the
situation
and so you're not appealing when you run
you're not appealing to
greater than 50 percent of people in
your state or your district
you're appealing to greater than 50
percent of people in your party
in your state or district and this kind
of setup
increases polarization in our elected
representatives over and over again you
can see this
it's explicit there is data okay if you
plot the
political beliefs of american voters
on some simplified left to right
spectrum you get kind of a bell curve
okay you get there's a lot of people in
the middle there are some people on
either sides
whereas if you plot the political
beliefs and actions
as uh as demonstrated by their voting
patterns
of our representatives in congress or
the senate or whatever
they're bimodal there are republicans
and democrats and they're cleanly
separated from each other
unlike the people they represent okay so
that's one element the other element is
if all you want
is to stay elected in other words as a
representative
or senator whatever if your goal is just
to win re-election
in other words it is not to necessarily
sacrifice your elected position for the
better of the country
so if all you want is to win election
and the way to win election is just to
appeal
to greater than 50 percent of the people
in your party
in your district the incentive is not
to govern the incentive is not to work
with people across the aisle the
incentive is not to make compromises
the incentive is not to do any of those
things that was taught or talked about
in the federalist papers
uh the federalists were you know just
scandalized at the at the worry
that there would be factions in the
united states right there be different
groups that hung together and were
enemies with each other
and of course they set up a system where
this was maximally true
so the founders kind of made some
mistakes to be honest they would not be
happy with the current system and
therefore maybe
we might imagine changing it but that's
a discussion for a different day
the point is that um the incentive
structure of people in
congress is not to get things done uh it
is
very much to demonize the other party as
the enemy
right and sometimes that's made very
explicit you can think of your own
examples
of quotes from this or that elected
representative
saying they just don't want the people
on the other side to get anything done
so that's not a necessary feature
of the system okay so if what we're
asking ourselves is
how fragile is democracy and can we
shore it up can we fix it
this is not necessarily an intractable
problem
it is a hard problem um but there are
possible solutions and i'm
again i'm not a political theorist and
so i'm not going to try to talk too much
out of my
uh bailiwick here but i have to you know
mention
one very popular suggestion which is
called ranked choice
voting probably you've heard of this
most of you but the idea that when you
go to vote for
let's say a senator from your state the
current system is you vote for
your favorite candidate and then you
count the votes and whoever wins wins
sometimes as we recently saw in the
state of georgia
if there are more than two candidates if
there are third party candidates or
whatever
there can be an extra rule that if
neither candidate if no candidate gets
more than 50 percent
then we have a runoff election okay you
can do that
but rank choice voting is kind of a way
to build that process into a single
election
so if you say rather than you just vote
for your favorite candidate
you vote for your three or four favorite
candidates
and you rank them so you say candidate
number one for me is this
here's my second favorite here's my
third favorite and
what they try to do is to say well did
anyone get more than 50
of the first place votes no well then
we'll take
all of the votes from the loser from the
person whoever got the fewest number of
votes
and we'll give them give their the
second place choices of those voters and
distribute them among the other
candidates
and you keep doing that until someone
gets more than 50 percent
the thing about this system is that it
lets you vote it lets you
it makes it matter who your second place
choice is
okay so it de-incentivizes demonizing
people from the other party because
in this system you want to be the voters
second place choice if you're not their
first place choice right
so you want to be as much of a
representative of the whole populace as
you possibly can be
and arguably we are seeing this in
action right this minute
um very recently like today or yesterday
and again
talking on january 9th 2021 uh lisa
murkowski who is the senator from alaska
uh alaska's extremely republican state
okay
no again because of political
polarization no democrat has a fighting
chance of winning
uh statewide election intellect in
alaska for for senate anyway
um and so murkowski is a republican has
been
um for a long time but she's a moderate
republican this has been her
you know uh self-image and
representation so she is willing
to you know consider breaking with her
party when she thinks it's the right
thing to do
and that can be annoying to everyone i'm
not saying it's necessarily a virtuous
thing i'm just saying that is what she
does
and she has made it clear that if the
republican party
continues to be ruled by donald trump or
trumpism or people who are pro-trump
then maybe it's not the party for her
right maybe she should not be republican
anymore
and the point is that alaska is one of
the very very few states in the united
states that has
ranked choice voting and in fact lisa
murkowski
it's a fascinating story that i wish
were more more known
she ran in a primary in the republican
primary in alaska
and lost she was not the republican
nominee but then she ran
as a write-in candidate in the general
election and won
because she was everyone's second choice
right roughly speaking
and so she knows that given the
electoral system
in her state she doesn't need to be as
extremist to win
a statewide election the argument can be
made and i don't want to defend the
argument right here but the argument can
be made and is absolutely worth taking
very seriously
that something like ranked choice voting
or other tweaks you can do to the
electoral system
will make the game theory calculation a
little bit
different and prioritize politicians
being more moderate
rather than more extreme and you can
argue about that's a good thing or a bad
thing
but it's a thing that you could imagine
doing and i would at least like to raise
the possibility that something like that
would be healthy for democracy again i'm
not even saying that it's necessarily
true it's a complicated question we
should think about
it but the the thing that i do want to
say is true is that the current system
in most states in most most locations
isn't necessarily set in stone
right we can imagine changes
to how we apportion representation
of citizens and it might actually make
democracy healthier rather than weaker
that's one thing we can try to do
the other thing that is worth keeping in
mind is
the other thing that the founders did
they were very very
concerned with minority rights right
this is where it does become important
that we're a republic not a democracy
so again democracy is actually pretty
broad
umbrella people instantly go people who
want to say bad things about democracy
instantly go from the word democratic
democracy to some sort of
extremist direct democracy where
literally every decision in government
is made by
majority vote among the whole people
okay and something like that was what
you had
in ancient athens and it was it's bad
because the whole people bless their
hearts
uh they you know can can have whims and
can change their minds very quickly okay
so you don't want to give
people the direct handles
of power in government you want to let
them elect representatives and let those
representatives do the work
and we call that a republic it's a
democratic republic because those
representatives
are elected by the people okay and so a
republic gives you the chance to protect
minority rights
and that's an important thing to do and
so the founders came up with various
uh mechanisms to make that happen one is
the united states senate
right the idea that every state gets two
senators
regardless of how many people it has
giving extra representation
to the certain minority namely people
who live
in less popular states okay now of
course
this is a zero-sum game if you give more
representation to people who live in
underpopulated states you're taking away
representation from people who live in
more populous states okay the relative
impact that i as a californian have in
the senate of the united states is way
way smaller than the relative impact of
that someone in wyoming or montana has
in the uni in the united states senate
and they also you know did the electoral
college where rather than a direct
popular vote for
um president you would each state would
vote and then that that's a little bit
fuzzier because it's a little bit
unclear
that the system is built into the
constitution in quite the same way
all of these are supposed to be
mechanisms that protect minority rights
the problem
is that to some extent they've been used
to enshrine
minority rule right the
since you know right now as we're still
we haven't yet had inauguration day et
cetera we have a republican president a
republican senate
a very republican supreme court the
house of representatives is democratic
right now but there's a lot of
republican power
and the net number of people represented
by that republican power
is much less than the number of people
who voted for democrats both in the
presidential elections and in the
congressional elections
and that's wrong i think that is a
mistake i am
a very big believer that minority rights
should be protected but that does not
mean
that we should hand over the power to
the minority right
there has to be a better way to
ensure that minority rights are
protected without
sacrificing majority rights the majority
has rights too and
the majority in of american voters for
many years now have been mostly voting
for democrats not by a lot
overall but um it has not been reflected
in electoral success in part because of
all these mechanisms that we enshrined
hundreds of years ago
to protect minorities so i don't have
any great suggestions as to how to do a
better job with this but i think this is
something we need to take
very seriously making if we want
democracy to survive we need to do a
better job
of making sure that the actual will of
the majority of the people
is reflected in the
rulers of the country in our
representatives in washington dc
and elsewhere while still protecting
minority rights
we should try to do that i don't have
any great scheme for doing that but
that's something we should try to do
okay which leads us to the next question
i want to talk about four out of five so
we're getting there
um how should we think about
let's say our opponents the people we
disagree with right
this is the thing about democracy that
is kind of
we don't want to face it sometimes um
when people
are for democracy they're very much for
the idea
that they get a vote right oh i'm not
being ruled by somebody else
i get a say because i get to vote and
this is good i'm being representative
represented in government but it also
means that those other jokers out there
get votes right and sometimes there are
more jokers and there are sensible
people like myself and they're going to
win
okay this is the cd underbelly of the
democratic
agreement namely that if most people
disagree with us
and and most people vote then our
opinion is not going to get
put forward in the government and this
can be very annoying
sometimes and sometimes it's merely
annoying right sometimes it's well
i really wish you know the tax rate were
higher the tax rate were lower or
whatever and it could be very annoying
and it can actually have a big impact on
people's lives don't get me wrong
but it's just clearly a relatively
rational policy kind of
disagreement other times it's kind of
big
right and especially because um trump
getting elected
and many of the people who sort of wrote
his coattails and followed in his
footsteps
did it in a way that seemed really
strongly
against certain segments of the american
people and certainly certain segments of
the wider international community right
there's a lot of
rhetoric directed against immigrants
against poor people against black people
and so forth
and so if you're someone who is the
target of this
if you are listening to people on the
other side of the political aisle
not just disagree with you about policy
but under
cut your very humanity right to really
you know question your right to exist or
your right to be counted as a full
citizen
and sometimes this is very indirect
right and very subtle like
um the idea that real americans
are rural people at diners rather than
uh urban people at jazz clubs right i
mean why is one
of those a real american and the other
one not or university professors for
that matter they can be real americans
right
there's this subtle picture of you know
norman rockwell
real america that has undercurrents of
not counting other people
as as real and so that can be something
that is very personal and very central
to your identity and it can be hard
to then say well even though these other
people
don't even think of me as a full human
being i have to sit down
and govern with them or you know work
with them and compromise them and reach
out across
the aisle okay um so
my suggestion is yes
we do we do have to do all of that
um this is what it means to live in a
democracy
uh you don't have to like the people who
you disagree with
you don't have to invite them over to
dinner but in some sense you have to
work with them you have to live with
them that's what it means
to be in a democracy so your choices are
treat those people as people and this is
completely you know the idea of both
sides ism
is a terrible bad thing uh because it it
leads to false equivalencies when one
side is being bad and the other side is
not
but this is not a both sides issue but
in every side issue it doesn't matter
what your specific views are
the ideal of democracy demands of us
that we work with the other side that we
accommodate them that we sometimes
compromise with them okay
and this has become harder to do because
of political polarization
uh you might want to if you haven't
already listened to them not only the
ezra klein interview but also
the uh conversation i had with will
wilkinson about the urban rural divide
and its relationship to political
polarization was extremely interesting
like there really are
different kinds of people economically
psychologically etc who live in cities
versus who live in rural areas
and that is now the primary driver of
polarization
in the united states and it's a
fascinating topic but but the point is
it's there
what whatever its origin is it's real
and the idea of living in democracy
demands that we somehow
nevertheless work together okay and that
can be a very very
difficult thing to do and it's not just
kind of a
in principle what attitude should i have
kind of questions a very practical
question you know we're facing
a time right now as we're about to go
from the trump administration to the
biden administration
where there's going to be a lot of calls
to investigate and punish
not just donald trump but people who
worked for him or with him or enabled
him right
a lot of bad things happened a lot of
crimes were committed
and um there's there's going to be a
real strong urge
for retribution right for punishment for
vengeance
it's sort of the flip side of um the
criminal justice system right when
when we talk about in the in the
principles or the philosophy of criminal
justice
why do you arrest people and put them in
jail there's a philosophy that says well
we're trying to rehabilitate them right
you know they went wrong
we're trying to fix them we're trying to
you know teach them something better but
there's another philosophy which is well
we're punishing them
they deserve it they did something wrong
uh i feel this is kind of as you can
tell it's more of a deontological
move and i'm against that in this
context but they're saying
it's just right that they are punished
in this way
and i think that's what drives a lot of
people's feelings about trump and his
cronies and his enablers and so forth
and even his supporters and i do want to
draw a distinction here so i think that
it's okay to be
um nuanced about this some things it's
not worth being nuanced about this is
something that is worth being nuanced
about
um i think we have to somehow move on
right we have to somehow get past the
uh acrimonious um atmosphere that we've
had
for years now but that does not imply
that we have to pretend that truly bad
criminal things didn't happen
or that we have to let them go
unpunished so here is a case
where um being consequentialist is
really really
important so the question we should ask
is not
does this or that person deserve
punishment
the question we should be asking is does
this or that person
does punishing them does does
uh implementing consequences for their
bad actions
make the world a better place does it
make it less likely that something is
going to happen
equally bad in the future i think it's
very easy to make the case that that is
often true
right i think it's very easy to make the
case that you shouldn't
let people in government who did bad
things
go scot-free afterwards you should
punish them i'm all in favor
of investigating uh you know not punish
them because we don't like them but if
they actually did
criminal things that can be proven in a
court of law they should face the
consequences the fact that they have
lots of supporters
the fact that they are heads of
political movements and served in public
office
is completely irrelevant because we
can't
let people going forward think that if
they get into power
they can get away with things okay but i
want to draw a distinction between
punishing
the political actors who did criminal
things
versus punishing their supporters who
let them do it
okay i think that's a different kind of
thing and
and here you know here it's almost sort
of therapy
self-help kind of thing and something
that i can only say very very
tentatively because if you can't go
along with this
i get it you know i'm sympathetic i know
i have a lot of
people i know a lot of friends who have
had their families dissolve
who have lost lifelong friends over the
last four years because of political
differences and i i'm a big believer in
political differences i don't think they
should be
ignored right political differences are
real uh and when you think that
people who you thought were your friends
or your family or
your loved ones and you can see them
support
a set of people and positions which in
your mind
are manifestly racist authoritarian
disastrous for the country in various
ways misogynist and so forth
um it's it makes absolute sense
to sort of not
keep going forward with those people as
friends
right you know i i i completely support
the idea
individually that um you can say look
you know i've learned something about
you in the past four years
that i don't like uh and on either side
i can imagine
people who are trump supporters feeling
the same way about
democrats as well but the point is as a
general principle
i think it's completely plausible and in
the right circumstances okay
to say that my personal relationship
with you has been irrevocably damaged
by our divergent opinions about this and
that political issue
nevertheless that's different than
saying
and yet you're a citizen of the united
states
and we gotta work together to figure out
how the country is going to move
forward so i am not one of these people
who makes fun
of joe biden for saying he wants to try
to work with republicans
now there is a case to be made
about naivete whether or not he will
succeed i think that this was a
big big problem in the early days of the
obama administration that they were just
far too naive about their ability to get
republicans to go along with them when
the republicans had said out loud they
were not going to do that so that was a
little bit naive
but you know what you still have to try
this is this is just the paradox of
democratic politics
even if you think that they're not going
to try to help you
you have to try to convince them
otherwise because that's what democracy
is all about
and also you know this uh i'll get
to this more in the next section um but
there are people you disagree with and
there are people you disagree with right
i mean there are people who
uh are just in trent entrenched yeah
and i said almost entrenched uh there
are people who are absolutely set in
their ways and nothing you will say to
them or nothing you can do to them will
ever change their minds
and other people who maybe you can work
with a little bit or who are a little
bit less intransigent
that matters that distinction matters a
little bit so
again this is very wishy-washy and um
also
it's easy for me to say you know look if
you want to accuse me of being you know
in a comfortable position where i can
say things like this
uh yeah that it's you're right i know
that what i'm asking is especially
difficult to ask of black people right
they have been spat on not just for last
four years but for the last 400 years
and to say okay well you know turn the
other cheek be the better person
try to build a better country by working
with the people who've treated you like
crap for centuries now
that's something that is a big ask and
it's not anyone
asking me that right i don't need to do
that so nevertheless it's an ask that i
would that i would make
um i think it's difficult and i think
that we need
to try to do it anyway uh i can't really
say any more wisdom than that
uh except the last question i wanted to
address here is this issue of
you know what can we programmatically do
constructively to try to make things
better to try to change the minds of
people of those people who we don't
agree with
so as i just said you know it's easy to
brush off this question how do we reach
across the aisle how do we try to change
people's minds by saying
look have you met these people they're
crazy
again both sides can say this they're
completely
looney tunes they have completely lost
the plot there's no reaching them
of course that's true for some people
out there and i think this this is one
of the
times when i completely buy the critique
of social media
and our fractured information ecosystem
that
it amplifies the crazies right on on any
individual side it is so much easier
these days
not just to find like-minded people
and live in a bubble and hear only
people we agree with
it's also so much easier to be exposed
to the worst
of the other side right we see pictures
of them we read their tweets
it's impossible to not be exposed to
them
so we can easily get the idea that
there's only two groups of people people
who agree with me
and complete lunatics right and if
that's what you think then it's easy to
lose motivation for trying to change
things at all right you just shrug and
you say like well it'll never happen
like these people are not
changeable um but i think that's a
misimpression of the actual facts on the
ground there are crazies out there on
there are extremists there are people
who never change their minds
um but there are also people in the
middle
like most people most americans anyway
the problem is not that they're rigid
ideologues on one extreme of the
spectrum or the other
is that they're kind of medium to low
information voters who don't care that
much you know i think a lot of people
voted for donald trump
because he was kind of entertaining he
was a talk show host he put on a good
show
right and you know the details of the
policy prescriptions didn't really
matter that much
i will always remember soon after the
election in november
you know there were a bunch of uh
rallies that were had
um people protesting the vote counting
and
because the way that it had worked out
was many of the republican
votes had been counted first because
they were voting on the day and it took
longer to count the mail-in votes
and so there were various states in
which early in the counting
trump was ahead and then as time went on
there were more and more democratic
votes coming in and biden
moved into the lead now as people as
epistemologists have pointed out
it's not that the actual results ever
changed right
biden had always won that election but
the count
was not released simultaneously so you
were counting in
uh homogeneously amongst the votes and
so the
the temporary count was different than
the final count okay
nevertheless given that situation there
was a set of people who wanted to stop
counting right like as soon as i'm ahead
to stop the game that's the way we
should have the rules right and so
there were there were people who were
you know encouraged to go around to
places where votes were being counted
and to try to stop it from counting now
what i remember
is that um someone and i forget who it
was sorry about that but some amusing
person went with a video camera
to one of these rallies and you know he
started sort of
leading you know chance about you know
go trump you know make america great
again etc
and then he started ranting about how we
need to count the votes like it's a
democracy he should count all the votes
and he got the whole crowd to start
chanting count the votes count the votes
which was exactly the opposite of what
they were there to demonstrate for but
within 10 minutes he convinced them all
that that's what they were in favor of
the point being that what they were
there for was not primarily motivated by
this particular policy you know this
particular uh suggestion that they
should count the votes or not count the
votes stop the count or whatever
uh but there was a sort of tribal
identification right they were there to
support
trump whatever that meant at the time
and if you changed what that meant they
would still
go along with that idea and what that
means to me
is that it can be easier than you think
to change people's minds because
what you're changing is sort of a
surface thing not a deep down thing like
i think for a lot of people they're just
not rigidly adhering to some particular
policy prescriptions and if you think
those policy prescriptions are what
matters at the end of the day
there's an enormous room to change
people's minds about those underlying
things there are studies that might
lead you to believe otherwise right i
mean there are studies by psychologists
political scientists
where you try to have some people with
an opinion you show them some
information
for that opinion or against that opinion
and then you ask them if their minds
have changed
and in many of these studies you know
they're hard to do there are replication
difficulties for many of these studies
etc but you
you can easily get depressed about how
hard it is to actually make
someone's mind change if you just look
at the results of these studies
but i think that i'm very skeptical of
these studies to be
honest for one thing i think that they
misrepresent how minds work how people's
opinions work
people are not perfect bayesian
reasoners as much as we would like to
aspire
to be people do not have a set of priors
that are well delineated and then
collect new data and update them
according to baze's formula
that's not what people do but that
doesn't mean that people don't change
their minds people change their minds
all the time what often happens is
something that can be very familiar to
physicists who know about phase
transitions
the thing that causes someone to change
their mind
might not be and in fact rarely is
the straw that broke the camel's back
right there can be a little thing that
they get a little piece of information
and experience whatever it is that is
associated in time
with the moment they change their mind
but the actual
cause of them changing their mind is a
set of many many things
stretching back in time okay you have a
person with an opinion with a belief
a credence and a certain proposition and
they get data that is against that
proposition and data in the very
broadest sense it's not like they're
being physicists but they get
information experiences news stories
conversations with friends that cause
them to
you know think about that particular
proposition and they don't change their
mind immediately because that's not how
people work
but that has an effect on them even if
the effect is invisible
at the level of their actual beliefs and
propositions
hearing that thing can nevertheless
affect them at a deeper level
and if they hear something else and
something else and something else over a
period of time
they can eventually be led to change
their mind without it ever being
possible to associate the reason for
that change
with a particular piece of information
that they got
not to mention the fact that often this
data in a very very broad sense is not
data in other words
the thing that is causing people to
change their minds
is not some piece of information or some
rational argument but something much
more visceral something much more
emotional
realizing that this person who is a
member of a group
that they have hated and denigrated for
years they meet a member of that group
and become friends with them
suddenly maybe their minds change right
uh you are against gay people getting
married and then you have a child who
turns out to be gay and wants to get
married
maybe you change your mind right for no
especially good reason
uh epistemically rationally but you
realize that i
wasn't really that devoted to that
opinion in the first place there are
many ways
to change people's minds and it really
does happen and all of this is just to
say
it's worth trying it's not worth trying
reaching out to the extremists to the
crazies but there are plenty of people
who are not like that there are plenty
of people who are just not that
devoted um and those people might not be
wedded to the views that they
very readily profess to believe in right
now
this is part of the challenge of
democracy those people
count just as much as the most informed
voters count
and of course there are hyper-informed
voters who are extremists on both sides
so it's not just a matter of
information levels but there are people
who
are in in principle and in practice
reachable and people who are not and we
should try to reach the ones who are
reachable and again
i would give that advice to the other
side as well if the other side thinks
that i
uh that they want to reach some people
who are on the opposite side they can
try to
um reach me and i'm here to be reached
right change takes time
um often it is not a matter of
marshaling better arguments it's just
setting a good example you know
providing people with a soft landing you
know one of the hardest things about
changing your mind politically
is that it is associated with a million
other things in your life right your
friendship networks your families etc
um your beliefs about many different
things you know the joke we had back in
george w bush's days um uh
i think michael berube was the first
person who made this joke but
you know the joke was well yeah i was a
lifelong democrat but then
9 11 happened and now i'm outraged about
chappaquiddick
the point is for those of you young
people out here chappaquiddick was this
uh scandal where ted kennedy uh was in a
automobile accident and mary jo kopechny
who was a woman who was in the car with
him
and he plunged into the river and she
died she drowned and he was able to swim
to shore and survived obviously and
continued in the senate and
you know republicans were outraged
though this was like you know a terrible
thing and democrats kind of made excuses
for it
and the joke being that once you change
your tribal political affiliation your
opinion about this historical event
changes along with it because these are
connected to each other and so
i want to sort of mention this in the
opposite way
also so not just that all of these other
opinions will change along with you if
you do change your mind about something
but that
in order to get someone to change their
mind you have to make it seem
reasonable for them to live in a whole
nother world
right for them to live in a world where
a whole set of beliefs are no longer
taken for granted
in a certain way that's what it means by
offering a soft landing one of the very
first
um podcasts i did was with tony pym
who is an atheist theologian who reaches
out to black communities and tries to
you know
spread the good word of atheism to them
and one of the points he made over and
over again is that black people are very
religious
in part because atheism does not provide
them with a soft landing you can make a
rational argument that god doesn't exist
but they need to figure out a way to
live their lives and in the lives of
many black communities
religion plays an important role and if
you simply say well we're not going to
replace that role
you got to learn to live with it then
they're not going to be persuaded to go
along with you
so part of persuading the other side and
reaching out to it is
making them feel welcome right and again
i get it
if this seems hard to do if this like if
you just want these people to be
punished and
they don't deserve it etc etc i get that
but that's going to make living in a
democracy harder for all of us if that's
the attitude we all
take so to close
um you know i think that let me go back
to the point
of how much democracy
demands of us because that's actually a
two-edged
argument living in a democracy taking
democracy seriously
suggests that every citizen every voter
or prospective voter eligible voter in
the
country needs to have some
responsibility to be informed about
politics to think carefully about who
they're voting for etc
so the flip side of that is that if you
want democracy to work
you should work to make sure that people
have access
to information and knowledge and
education
okay that people are able to
put in the time and the resources and
the thought power
to think about the country and other
people
if you want people to be empathetic and
understanding of people in different
circumstances
then you have to expose them to people
in different circumstances you have to
let people have experiences that take
them outside of their bubble
economics health education equality
all of these go into having a healthy
democracy you know i talked in a fairly
narrow political way
about our political system and how it
might be made more robust
which i think is important but it's not
nearly as important as just
creating a fair equitable society for
everyone
uh give people education give people
health care give people jobs
give people a feeling that they have
prospects
they have a future i mean we've all seen
these statistics
of how you know the tiny fraction of
wealth
that is you know in the hands of people
who are roughly age 30
now compared to what it was 50 years ago
you know 50 years ago
uh people of in the generation that was
at that time 30 years old
at that time owned a far larger fraction
of the wealth of the country
than the 30 year olds do today we we've
created a society not only in which
wealth is
more concentrated than ever in the hands
of rich people
but in the hands of old people right so
we're making it
perfectly reasonable for young people to
be frustrated and
that's bad that's a recipe for disaster
that's uh asking for trouble
okay so all of these uh hopes
for economic equality
and relief from debt and access to
health care
these aren't just good because they're
good they're good you know
i think it's good that people have um
access to all these wonderful things as
basic human dignities
they're also important for democracy
right if you want someone to be
informed if you want them to really
think about the information sources
they're getting
and and try to separate the [ __ ]
from
the facts etc it helps enormously
if they sort of had the powers to do
that and the time to do that and the
resources to do that
uh it's not a fair race if some people
are more burdened than
others we can think about you know basic
income universal education whatever it
is but all these policies
should be thought of not just for their
immediate short-term economic impacts
but for their service in the cause of
keeping democracy
thriving as a you know
privileged academic i would even go so
far as to say that
cosmopolitanism liberal education the
humanities
uh not to mention of course science and
math and all that stuff all that stuff
but being educated in the world in a
broad sense
it seems almost obvious it seemed almost
sort of cliched and too obvious to be
said out loud that this is really
important for a functioning democracy
you have a bunch of people who in whom
the responsibility of governing the
country
is being put well it's in all of our
best interests if those people
are as well educated and exposed to the
world in all of its many fold wonders
as we can possibly allow them to be
right and in this case
those people are everybody so
economic justice and equality and access
to uh good things education and ideas
and philosophy and history
and literature all of those things
should be part of
watering the soil in which democracy
grows if you want to put it that way
and is it going to work is it going to
happen are we going to be okay
you know i don't know i'm not going to
make any predictions here i
i want to be optimistic about democracy
because i like it and i think that there
is a lot of
robustness to our current institutions
but
um it could go all disastrously wrong i
mean we've seen that we've seen it in
other countries and we're not that
special
in here in the united states shout out
to all those listeners who are not in
the united states i know i hope
that i'm saying something interesting to
you also but i'm here in the united
states we're in the middle of kind of a
crisis right now so that's what i'm
thinking about
um i think that we should act as if
democracy could die at any moment right
that's what we should have in mind
and we should be asking ourselves how to
make it healthier how to push it forward
how to protect it
a lot of that means how to get along
with and work with the people who are
not on
our side that's the challenge let's see
whether we can live up to it
[Music]
you